There are a variety of very complex
things facing us and one of them is
called the Iq issue that we talked
about.
Another is this polarization between
left and right.
That seems to be characterizing
everywhere in the West,
you know,
it's the same in Australia,
New Zealand,
all through Europe,
in Canada,
in the US.
I think you guys are actually a little
more protected against the most places.
But um,
and then the other one is,
well we need a dialogue between Islam
and Christianity and Judaism for that
matter.
But I mean the big,
the big clash for,
for the Western world is,
is Islam versus Christianity and you
know,
people don't think about it in those
terms because many intellectuals in the
west think of themselves as secular,
but it's a massive,
it's a massive problem.
And I'm hoping to conduct a whole series
of conversations with,
with Muslims,
a former and present pro and anti to try
to facilitate a dialogue because there's
lots to talk about.
I mean,
I've studied religious thinking a lot
and I'm pretty ignorant about Islam
because it's complicated system and it's
difficult to get into.
But I can tell you that what I've read
about Islam has not made me feel better
about the chances of reconciliation
between the Christian and the Islamic
world.
So like I don't know what to make of the
fact,
for example,
I mean if you look at the figure of
Christ and I don't care if you're
religious or not,
and I don't even care a Christ existed
or not,
and I certainly don't care at the moment
about claims to divinity or the lock
there up.
I'm just speaking as let's say I'm
speaking as a secondary intellectual
mean as a figure.
He's a figure of peace.
I don't think that that's disputable.
I mean,
he certainly,
he wasn't a war Lord.
That's one thing.
That's for certain he never led armies,
you know,
whereas that's not the case with
Mohammed at all.
Muhammad was clearly and indisputably a
war Lord.
And so it isn't the obvious to me what
to make of that except that it's bloody
complicated.
Had a child bride as well,
I believe.
Yeah.
Well,
that one is somewhat less problematic to
me because I think that you can write
that off to the cultural mores of the
time.
Now I'm.
I know that there's a weakness in that,
but I don't think we have to address
that,
but the wind,
the founder of your religion spread that
religion by the sword.
It makes it rather difficult and when
your religion has been embroiled in a
vicious civil war from the day of
Mohammed's death,
which is exactly the case in Islam
between the Sudanese and the and the
Shiites,
that war started literally the day that
Mohammed died.
It's very difficult for me to see how
that could be reconciled with the claims
that Islam is a religion of peace.
Yeah.
We solved that one when Martin Luther
hammered some stuff on a door a long
time ago and the Protestants and the
Catholics just went their separate ways
and I mean there's been some rough
feelings over the years I suppose,
but no generational wars that I can
think of.
I mean,
right.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean there was plenty,
you know,
as you said,
there were.
There's been plenty of Christian schism,
but the other thing too is that it's not
that easy to lay those at the feet of
Christ.
No,
because because just even merely as an
archetypal figure,
you know,
as,
as the western world's hypothesis of the
ideal man.
I mean,
as a moral character,
he was pretty much above reproach and I
don't.
Well,
it's difficult for me to say the same
thing about Muhammad now.
That might be because I'm an ignorant
all western white guy,
but like I'm doing my best man.
I'm a big buyer of Taoism for example,
and there's great wisdom in Taoism and
I've found value real value in,
in so much of the religious reading that
I,
that I've done,
but I'm really stumbling with Islam.
It's really hard for me to,
to see it as other than a primarily
political system
and did.
And that's how it's being imply enforced
right now with wwe,
that's what Isis is all about.
Their estate establish a religious
caliphate,
you know,
across the borders of two,
two countries.
It's,
it's less about.
When I think of religion,
when I think of the Christian religion
and how it's applied here in my home
state of Georgia,
you know,
it's when,
when,
when we go to church and we tie,
that has very little to do with politics
at all.
There's,
there's,
there's this huge,
massive separation between religion and
politics for the most part in the US and
to be,
there are moments of ambiguity and,
and tempers flare over and I'm a
monument on this piece of property or
no,
but that's as stiff as it gets.
Like,
like the scariest bit of that that I can
remember.
Some drunk fellow ran over a monument or
the 10 commandments a few months ago and
tipped it over.
Like,
like,
like that's what happens when
I agree to your point,
like if you're not a Christian Kyle and
you're,
you know,
Christian kind of alcove there in
Georgia,
no one ever is going to come to you and
say you have to pay a different rate of
taxes.
You have to go to different stores.
You have the religious law will not be
enforced
as a law.
You know,
I'm not gonna lose any hands.
Uh,
if I,
I can,
you know,
the Bible has many restrictions that it
places on Christians and I ignore all of
them virtually,
you know,
like,
but I don't,
I know there's no,
like there's no
religious police to come and kick my
door in and drag me away and torture me
and threatened my family and,
and.
Well,
let me,
it's also,
there's other,
there's other cataclysms that are on the
that exist on the conceptual,
the conceptual realm as well.
So you know,
the,
the state's dominated by Islam are not
economically productive and that's quite
an interesting mystery and
they're not.
And many of the many of the Islamic
states that we purport to regard as
allies hold values that are antithetical
to our system and a,
Saudi Arabia is a classic example of
that.
And I cannot for the life of me
understand,
except in a psychoanalytic matter why
the radical feminists tolerate America's
ally.
America's lie.
The fact that America is allied with the
Saudis,
it's just absolute.
It's like,
it's like it's not much different as far
as I'm concerned that it would be if
black people didn't say anything.
If America was allied with a slave
owning a black slave owning state,
which of course also happens in Saudi
Arabia by the way,
and not
so when did the feminist.
It's gotta be because Muslims right now
are higher up on the victim hierarchy
than then,
so even if it's way over there,
they're not allowed to speak out against
them.
I think it's their unconscious wish for
brutal male domination.
No,
I like that.
That's fun.
I think it's the left's ability to
apologize for anything that's wrong.
I think the people on the left,
and maybe I'm just as crazy as you guys
are,
like I said,
the Muslims are oppressed women.
Oh,
that's cultural.
We need to understand that.
Oh guys think they're girls that you
know,
hey,
we need to understand where they're
coming from.
Everything.
They're so open minded to it,
even if it's horrific.
Yeah.
That's also the agreeableness say that
we were talking about earlier.
Yeah,
because agree,
agreeable people agree,
you know,
that's why the term exists and yeah,
so there is a real apology and if you
ally that with high openness,
which is that open mindedness,
you know,
that that's associated activity,
you get agreeable openness and yeah,
that's definitely.
And then it even goes,
I'll call and I'll forgive you beating
your wife and if you're low in
conscientiousness,
everything keeping really goes.
Then Bill Moore puts it nicely when he
says,
you know,
the lift would not for one second be
okay with apartheid in South Africa,
right?
They were just banging that drum hating
every second of the way,
but for some reason the oppression of
women in Saudi Arabia has gotten a
complete pass.
Yup.
And it's a real deal.
You know,
what
the heck?
Just the driving thing alone.
Taylor,
can you hold it that they liked her?
Yeah,
I broke up.
You broke that.
We couldn't hear what you were saying
that you're still a little frozen.
So,
um,
uh,
but yeah,
just taking away their ability to drive.
Right?
Women don't have mobility without men.
That is hugely oppressive.
If you made that change in America and
none other than our wellness stuff,
dude,
you actually don't see a more concrete
embodiment of the idea of individual
autonomy than the automobile.
You know,
I think maybe it was the Soviet Union's
import and then,
and then,
uh,
a manufacturer if the automobile,
the doom,
communism because nothing screams
autonomous individual like a car,
right?
You will derive it yourself.
You can go on any road.
No one tells you what to do.
It's like it's freedom.
And the fact that women can't drive in
Saudi Arabia,
it tells the entire story.
And so the fact I cannot understand for
the life of me why we are so blind in
the west,
that we make the assumption that those
people are our allies.
Like in what way?